Patrick is an Ohio hi Patrick welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show
good afternoon Dave Allen I just wanted
your I just wanted your opinion on
something through poor planning and not
maybe and other things could could this
is if we don't get some good it if we
don't have good leadership and sound
thinking could this economy actually
crash I mean it sounds like that this
was just more of a knee-jerk reaction
shutting down a capitalistic country
that runs on capitalism and I think
anybody could have come up with just hey
let's just stay home and not go to work
I mean it doesn't sound like there was a
lot of planning put into this if I was
gonna do it myself I would probably have
somebody such as yourself I would
surround myself such as persons like you
maybe in Mohamed el-erian that used to
run Penco things of that nature there
doesn't seem like there's been a lot of
plan put into this I just like the
opinion on that well I don't know that
my opinion matters number one because I
really don't there's been a there's been
a lot of bad data around the whole
subject and and it was sold to everyone
as good data regarding the economy
regarding the virus regarding what the
effect of the stimulus would be and
those kinds of things and it's very
obvious to the general public that they
cannot trust the economic data the virus
data and the the models are all broken
and so that's the problem is that people
don't have faith in the information that
they're getting and the Bible says where
there is no vision the people perish and
so that's why
you've got one group of people are
sitting at home dutifully avoiding
social contact and another group
protesting to get their jobs back and
one is afraid of the economy one is
afraid of the virus but the ones that
are afraid of the economy are obviously
more afraid of the economy than they are
the virus the ones that are afraid of
the virus are obviously more afraid of
the virus than they are the economy and
it may be their personal situation there
they may be health compromised or they
may be economically compromised and they
don't have the option to the luxury to
be panicked about the other one but
either way they're not people are not
making decisions with a and the leaders
aren't making this haven't made
decisions with accurate information and
that's what's throwing people is that
they've lost people have lost confidence
especially in the media because it's
just been one big swath of hysteria and
then it's been proven time and time
again that it wasn't right the models
weren't right obviously people got sick
and obviously some died and those are
horrible situations so is it is the
leadership and the confidence in the
information so broken that we completely
collapse as a society if that's your
question the answer is no we are more
resilient than stupidity because I was
just wondering financial because it
seems like we have politicians that run
this when we actually need people that
are a business or of sound thinking and
it seems like critical thinking debate
seems like it's gone out the window
yeah the politician and it depends on
who's got their ear whether it's someone
with a car coronavirus curve or someone
with an unemployment curve who has their
ears to which ones are reacting which
ways but I can tell you this again I'll
just keep referring back to this but
I've watched this kind of stuff not a
virus but I watched other stuff unfold
and the American people are
several things one is were rebellious
and we don't just accept an answer
blindly we're not a you know this a
certain group of people are a bunch of
sheep but there's a bunch of people
America are not sheep and they're not
going to accept things that that just
continue to be inaccurate you can't keep
me at home and not working with the
accuracy of the curves you put out there
that's what a lot of people are saying
now and they're also saying on the other
hand they don't want anybody to get sick
and they're worried about their mother
and they're worried about their kid and
they've got a respiratory issue and a
immune compromised or whatever and those
are all very real things so again people
are making their own decisions but
people are resilient number one number
two they're rebellious and they're not
going to just accept things
carte-blanche laying down and and I
don't think the politicians have as much
control as they think they do some of
these states are starting to see it
there's going to be uprisings and on the
economic side of the front and there
might have been on the health side had
it not subsided somewhat on a national
level so anyway all that to say I'm
pretty hopeful right now I'm more
hopeful for the US economy and for our
health than I was three weeks ago
it appears we're moving back to work and
it appears we're moving away from the
sickness and Kristi you're hearing a lot
of people work through fear issues
anxiety issues aren't you yeah and I
love what you said about that were
rebellious and we're resilient because
what's amazing is and there's such
parallels between business and life
anyway but the the quality of just
simply not taking no for an answer
being perseverant being persistent just
never giving up and you talk about this
in entree leadership but yes there are
going to be real things we need to deal
with right now in the economy in your
business with restrictions with the
coronavirus that type of thing but it
doesn't mean this is the time to tuck
our tail go home and give up this
doesn't mean it's time to play the
victim and go well these things yeah
they're real things that happen and
again we can persevere and again we can
persist and again we are resilient so I
think just choosing to have those
character qualities will make the
difference of how you get through this
and how you come out on the other side
yeah that's exactly right and it does
work I mean you can
we will be okay and but you know you do
have that we're not gonna take any more
thing that happens and it happens on all
kinds of fronts it doesn't have to just
be that the the current protests we have
over the economy and those kinds of
things but it became apparent about four
weeks ago that the Cure was going to
affect a lot more people than the virus
we were statistically we're going to be
sure that that the stay at home orders
and the shutting down the economy you
know we now have 22 million people
unemployed and you know well we don't
want anybody sick I understand but
people are always going to be sick and
that's not cold hearted that's just the
way it is and it it is it is official
you know more in families have been
impacted by far a hundred families have
been impacted for every one case of
coronavirus that we've had economically
impacted so it's official statistically
but again that's not to say that there
was another way or a different way the
information has been so diluted and
wrong that I mean when some of these
guys come out with a model and then they
come back and there are thousands of a
percentile off with their models on the
virus spread and really for that matter
on what's going to happen with the
economy these people they're you know
it's it's hard for someone who's not a
sheep to have trust in either ones of
the discussions carte blanche to just
say you know whatever you say governor
whatever you say mayor whatever you say
president Trump whatever you say Nancy
Pelosi I'm just going to go with it the
chances of Americans just doing that in
mass when the information is proven time
and time again to be inaccurate is just
not going to happen it's just not going
to happen and it's not that people are
necessarily going to you know carry
pitchforks and torches to the Capitol
although they are in a
you states are starting to in Tennessee
but now Tennessee starting to open up
and that's kind of done away with the
need for the protesters so I think most
of them have gone home in that regard
but yeah it's just it's a it's a weird
time and there's a lot of really good
leadership lessons for your home your
business and your government that have
been violated in this process that you
can take away and sometimes you need an
anti mentor and there's quite a few of
them out there right now this is the
Dave Ramsey show